foreign
[Music]
and I'm going to give you a quick start
on how to get started with immersive
stream for XR and the corresponding
unreal template project
we will have a look at all the assets
the blueprints and the logic and the
level and this will hopefully give you a
quick start on how to kick off your own
projects
note that we will not be covering the
gcp stream API in this tutorial
be sure to check our knowledge base for
materials demos tutorials and the full
documentation that show specific use
cases and features in more detail
so let's kick it off
after downloading the template zip file
unpack it and move the new folder into
your unread projects folder
you can also rename the folder in the
project file if you like
if you already have unreal version 5.0
installed you are good to go
if not go back to the epic games
launcher and install unreal version 5.0
from there
now that you have your template project
unpacked and ready open it up in unreal
5.0
let's have a look at our level setup in
the levels window first
as a general approach in immersive
stream for XR we are using a main
persistent level which is called main
persistent and that is able to load
different streaming levels depending on
the use case
if we have a look at the photo structure
in the content browser you here you can
find six descriptive folders blueprints
global maps movies starter assets and UI
let's start with the maps folder here
you can find all the relevant levels to
do your first tests
by default Unreal Engine opens the level
main persistent that holds three other
levels that you can see here
the level of 3D background holds the
background for the 3D mode and contains
an hdri backdrop and a directional light
the AR background level
is used when a user is switching into
the AR mode it holds a static lighting
setup with a directional light a
skylight a shadow plane to receive
shadows and a post process volume the
content start level is the place where
we want to focus on in the beginning
this level gets loaded by default
together with the 3D background level
when the experience starts right now you
only see if we have a look into it and
change the scene to unlit
here in the world outliner you see
there's only a touch example BP
blueprint in there where we will have a
look into in the next section
now let's have a look at the blueprints
folder here you can find all the
relevant blueprints for immersive stream
for XR to work
most important is the XR init blueprint
where you can change the default content
level and more
in the respective subfolders you can
find the general blueprints for AR mode
for the editor utility widget and more
in the UI folder you can find blueprint
widgets and other elements that are user
interface related
Global holds the global project data
like a material collection the cube map
blueprints the controller and more
now let's have a more detailed look at
the blueprints
in the folder starter assets there's the
touch example BP blueprint let's have a
look into that
in the viewport of this blueprint you
can see it has a tooltip and a mesh with
the corresponding variable name to be
able to access them programmatically
in the event graph you can see that
there's already a touch event handling
implemented that is changing the mesh
from sphere to Cube and back and it's
triggering the visibility of the tooltip
element
the next blueprint we look into is the
XR init blueprint that you can find in
the blueprints folder
if you open it up you can see some logic
being executed in the event graph tab
running int commands loading Blueprints
and loading the initial levels
in the details window you can change
basic information like the start level
for example
now let's talk about using your own
assets
to get started with that you need to
import the assets into ideally a new
folder in the content browser
in my case I'm creating a folder called
custom
I go into it
and then I hit the import button on the
top of the content browser
then I select the asset
I import everything and wait until the
import is finished
from there I go into the content browser
again move to the folder Maps and open
up the content start map because that's
the map where your content can be placed
easily
here I can drag the assets into the
scene
I can move it around scale it rotate it
as I need
previewing your project locally is very
easy
to preview your project including the
system UI you can either simulate or
play from the main persistent map
note that we created the project with
the 500 by 1000 pixel viewport
please keep this setting to preview the
experience as close as possible to how a
mobile user would see it
congratulations on working with your
first project with immersive stream for
EXA
I hope you found the video useful
you can find all the relevant
information links and more resources in
the video description
I wish you a great day see you soon and
bye